.
PRESIDENT BIDEN LOSING TOUCH
WITH REALITY WITH JUST 27 DAYS
TO GO UNTIL MIDTERMS.
AFTER DECIMATING AMERICAN ENERGY
LETTING INFLATION UP TO RECORD
HIGHS, ALLOWING HISTORIC FLOW OF
MIGRANTS ACROSS THE BORDER AND
UNLEASHING A VIOLENT CRIME SURGE
BIDEN IS DELUSIONAL ENOUGH TO
THINK AMERICA LOVES WHAT HE'S
DOING.
>> LOOK WHAT I GOT DONE.
NAME ME A PRESIDENT IN RECENT
HISTORY GOT AS MUCH DONE AS I
HAVE THE FIRST TWO YEARS.
YOU MAY NOT LIKE WHAT I GOT DONE
BUT VAST MAJORITY OF AMERICAN
PEOPLE LIKE WHAT I GOT DONE SO
IT'S A MATTER OF CAN YOU DO THE
JOB AND I BELIEVE I CAN DO THE
JOB, I'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THE
JOB.
>> NOT A JOKE.
IF BIDEN THINKS HE'S SO GREAT
WHY ARE SO MANY VULNERABLE DEMPS
AFRAID TO BE SEEN IN PUBLIC WITH
HIM?
BIDEN THINKS THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY HAS NOTHING TO CAMPAIGN
ON.
>> WHAT'S THE REPUBLICAN
PLATFORM?
WHAT ARE THEY RUNNING ON?
WHAT ARE THEY FOR?
FIRST THING THEY SAID THEY'RE
GOING TO GET THROUGH THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT.
WHAT'S THAT GOING TO DO?
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE FOR.
>> EVEN BERNIE SANDERS IS
BEGGING DEMOCRATS TO LISTEN TO
THE PEOPLE WHO GET THEM ELECTED
AND FOCUS ON TOP POLLING ISSUES
THAT VOTERS ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT
A CONCEPT THE DEMOCRATS JUST
SEEM NOT TO BE ABLE TO GRASP.
>> I THINK THE SUPREME COURT'S
DECISION WAS AN OUTRAGE IT IT
HAS TO BE AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
THIS CAMPAIGN BUT IT CANNOT BE
THE ONLY ISSUE.
POLL AFTER POLL SHOWS WHAT
EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS TO BE
TRUE.
WORKING PEOPLE ARE HURTING.
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
ECONOMY.
THEY'RE WORRIED ABOUT INFLATION.
>> SO JOE BIDEN COMES OUT AND
SAYS EVERYBODY LOVES WHAT I'VE
DONE.
HOW IS THAT GOING TO FLY?
>> WELL, IT'S GOING TO BE BAD.
>> CAN'T SEE YOU AGREE WITH
THAT.
>> I THINK I'M GOING TO AGREE
WITH A LOT OF WHERE THE TEAM IS
GOING TO GO.
I DO THINK THAT BIDEN HAS DONE
SOME THINGS.
I THOUGHT THE BEST PART OF WHAT
HE SAID YOU MAY NOT AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING I'VE DONE BUT THE
INFLATION REDUCTION ACT, WE
SHOULD BE DRILLING MORE HERE TO
INCREASE OUR DOMESTIC SUPPLY.
THE CHIPS ACT WHICH IS GOING TO
ALLOW US TO MAKE JAVELINS HERE
AND SEMICONDUCTORS AS NATIONAL
REFORM ISSUE.
GUN REFORM WHO WOULD HAVE
THOUGHT THE REPUBLICANS WITH THE
HOUSE IN THE SENATE, SOME OF THE
REPUBLICANS WHO VOTED AGAINST
THE INFRASTRUCTURE BILL ARE A
LYING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY
IN THEIR DISTRICT.
FINALLY I THINK HE'S RIGHT IN
ONE REGARD.
YOU LOOK AT WHAT RICK SCOTT THE
RENEWAL FOR AMERICA PLAN.
McCARTHY HAS THE COMMIT TO
AMERICA.
NEWT GINGRICH RAN ON THE
CONTRACT WITH AMERICA.
I THINK WE ARE REPUBLICANS HAVE
EXPLAINING TO DO AS YOU WOULD
SAY IN POLITICS.
WE WILL SEE IF THEY'RE ABLE TO
DO IT.
I THINK THE BEST THING ABOUT
THIS REPUBLICANS WHETHER ONE OR
TWO THINGS THEY STAND FOR THEY
HAVE A MONIKER OUT THERE AND
HAVE TO DEFEND IT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE A MONIKER.
PROBABLY HALF THE DEMOCRATS WANT
BIDEN THERE CAMPAIGNING WITH
HIM.
THEY ALL WANT HIM TO RAISE MONEY
BUT NOT EVERYONE WANTS HIM
CAMPAIGNING.
WE WILL SEE HOW IT WORKS OUT
NEXT THREE WEEKS BUT THIS RACE
IS TIGHT IN THE SENATE.
50 SEATS WERE WHAT REPUBLICANS
WERE EXPOSED TO WIN 8 WEEKS AGO.
I THINK REPUBLICANS HAVE AN
ADVANTAGE IN THE HOUSE.
IT'S A JUMP BALL IN THE SENATE.
>> HAROLD RATTLES OFF THINGS
THEY GOT PAST.
ANYBODY CAN COOK A LOT OF MEALS
BUT IF PEOPLE DON'T THINK IT
TASTES GOOD SO WHAT?
>> IT REMINDS ME WHEN JOE SAYS
EVERYBODY LOVES HIM.
IT'S LIKE IF A GIRL BREAKS UP
WITH A BOYFRIENDS AND BE DOESN'T
SAY ANYTHING BAD ABOUT THE
BOYFRIEND BUT SHE'S BROKEN UP
WITH HIM AND ONTO A NEW GUY BUT
BOYFRIEND SAYS SHE LOVES ME.
NO SHE DOESN'T.
SHE'S ON TO THE NEXT GUY.
THAT'S LIKE JOE BIDEN IN THIS
COUNTRY.
>> I AGREE WITH THAT.
>> THEY'RE LIKE ONTO THE NEXT
GUY BUT WAY THINK THAT I THINK
THAT BERNIE SANDERS IS SMART BUT
BERNIE SANDERS ALWAYS UNDERSTOOD
THE WORKING PEOPLE.
HE UNDERSTANDS IT'S ABOUT THE
KMOENL.
HE'S SMART ENOUGH TO TELL THE
DEMOCRATS THAT'S WHAT YOU HAVE
TO FOCUS ON.
WHAT THE REPUBLICANS HAVE TO
FOCUS ON IS CRIME AND THE BORDER
AND EVERYDAY I JUST SEE IT AND
SAY IT CAN'T GET ANY WORSE.
BUT EVERY DAY IT DOES GET WORSE.
SO I THINK THAT JOE BIDEN IS I
DON'T THINK HE'S GOING TO END UP
RUNNING IN 2024 BUT I ALSO THINK
THAT THE PARTY IS RUNNING FROM
HIM MORE THAN ARE STICKING WITH
HIM
>> JEANINE AND BERNIE SANDERS
BOTH MAKE GREAT POINTS IF YOU
HAVE THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE BY A
MILE WHICH IS THE ECONOMY, THE
DEMOCRATS DON'T EVEN TALK ABOUT
THE ECONOMY.
>> HOWEVER, BERNIE SANDERS IS
NOT THAT SMART BECAUSE THE BILL
THAT BIDEN PASSED WAS IF
BLUEPRINT FROM BERNIE.
WHAT DOES THAT RESULT IN?
INCREASED INFLATION.
WHAT BERNIE SANDERS WANTS TO DO
IS SPEND MORE MONEY.
THAT'S NOT VERY SMART BUT HE IS
SMART TO BE ABLE TO SAY I'M NOT
BIDEN, I WOULD BE DIFFERENT, YOU
GOT TO DO THIS OR THAT AND HE
TRIES TO BE ALL THINGS TO ALL
PEOPLE, NOT WHAT AMERICANS ARE
FOR.
BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY IS GETTING A
ONE STAR YELP REVIEW BUT HE SAYS
I'M DOING GREAT.
WHEN WE GET HIS CLIPS ALL THE
NEWSPAPER HOLLARS GIVE --
ARTICLES THAT MAKE THINGS LOOK
GOOD ATMORE THING HAPPENING HERE
IS MIDTERM ELECTION WHEN YOU
HAVE ONE PARTY RULE, THAT MEANS
IT'S A CHECK ON ONE PARTY RULE
AND IT'S A REFERENDUM ON BIDEN.
IT'S NOT A CHOICE BETWEEN BIDEN
AND TRUMP OR WHOEVER ELSE SO
PEOPLE ARE GOING SOY SAY WHAT
CAN THE REPUBLICANS DO.
THE NUMBER ONE THING THE
REPUBLICANS WANT TO DO IF THEY
TAKE THE MAJORITY IS SYMPTOM BAD
THINGS FROM HAPPENING.
THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE JOB.
THEN THEY CAN TALK ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE FOR.
THE HOUSE IF THE REPUBLICANS
TAKE OVER THEY'RE GOING TO PASS
SO MANY BILLS AND BIDEN IS GOING
TO IGNORE THEM AND YOU KNOW WHAT
HAPPENS AS SOON AS IT'S CALLED
WHO HAS THE MAJORITY IN THE
SENATE AND THE HOUSE FIRST THING
IS WE ARE ON TO THE 2024
ELECTION.
>> LAST NIGHT HE SAID HE HASN'T
DECIDED WHETHER HE'S RUNNING OR
NOT.
>> WHEN HE SAYS THAT REPUBLICANS
HAVE NOTHING TO RUN ON HE'S
WRONG.
THEY CAN RUN ON HIM AND THEY CAN
RUN ON THE DEMOCRATS WHO
CONTINUE TO DENY THE CLAIM THAT
CRIME DOESN'T EXIST THAT
INSFLAIGS A MIRAGE AND THE
BORDER IS SECURE.
THEIR STRATEGY IS LIKE A DRUG
ADDICT IN INTERVENTION.
LIKE NOTHING HAPPENING HERE.
GUT HAS BEEN LIKE A LONG
EXERCISE IN DE -- SMELLS JUST
LIKE, IT'S ALMOST JUST LIKE THE
HIDING THE BLACKTOP.
HERE'S THE BIG PROBLEM.
LET'S BURY IT, HIDE IT OR DELAY
IT SO IT WON'T HURTIES
POLITICALLY.
SO HE DIDN'T REALLY CARE THAT
THE AMERICANS WERE SUFFERING AT
THE GAS PUMP.
HE JUST DIDN'T WANT IT TO AFFECT
THE DEMOCRATS.
THAT'S KIND OF SLEESY.
IN THE MIDST OF THIS ECONOMIC
MALAISE, CRIME WAVES, WE HAVE
GOT A WAR GOING ON, IT'S LIKE
WASHING YOUR WINDOWS AS YOUR
HOUSE IS ON FIRE Y. ARE THEY
DOING THIS?
I THINK PEOPLE SHOULD NOT WATCH
THAT HEARING SYMBOL I CAN TO SAY
WE HAVE HAD ENOUGH OF THIS
CIRCUS.
WE GOT REAL PROBLEMS HERE AND
NONE OF THEM ARE POLITICAL.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY FAMILY ECONOMIC
PROBLEMS.
WE DON'T LOOK AT OUR PROBLEMS
POLITICALLY.
THAT'S WHY THE DEMOCRATS ARE
BETTER ON THE OUTSIDE, AND
REPUBLICANS ARE BETTER ON THE
INSIDE.
REPUBLICANS IN POWER ACTUALLY
ATTACK THINGS THAT AMERICANS
WANT LIKE CRIME AND LIKE THE
BORDER.
DEMOCRATS ARE GOOD AT ATTACKING
REPUBLICANS.
>> YES THEY ARE.
>> SO KEEP THEM ON THE OUTSIDE,
IT'S LIKE A NICE LITTLE
MARRIAGE.
>> LOT OF ANALOGIES THERE.
>> YES, NONE OF THEM MADE SENSE.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO BE EXCITED
TO WATCH THE JANUARY 6 HEARINGS
TOMORROW?
>> I PROBABLY WON'T WATCH THEM
BUT HOLDING SOMEBODY ACCOUNTABLE
IS IMPORTANT.
>> DO YOU THINK DOING AT THIS
TIME SAME DAY AS THE INFLATION
NUMBERS DROPS IS GOOD POLITICS?
>> REMEMBER JESSE THEY WERE
EXPOSED TO HAVE THE HEARINGS TWO
WEEKS AGO BUT THE HURRICANE
HAPPENED AND THEY MOVED IT SO
THEY WOULDN'T GET BLOWN OUT ON
COVERAGE.
>> VERY WELL DONE.
LOT OF GOOD ANALOGIES AROUND THE
TA